on confie la responsabilité de continuer
à gouverner
mais rien de tout ça n'aurait été
possible sans les efforts et les
sacrifices de beaucoup beaucoup de monde
qui donne énormément de gens remercie
donc c'est sûr que je pensais pas mal de
temps on téléphone au cours des
prochains jours
mais ce soir et quelques personnes en
particulier que je à qui je dois dire
merci
d'abord ma sophie
on a commencé cette aventure politique
ensemble plus de dix ans parce que on
croyait en un avenir meilleur
parce qu'on savait que ça valait la
peine de se battre pour un canada plus
fort et plus prospère
sophie je suis tellement chanceuse
d'avoir à mes côtés
[Applaudissements]
merci mon amour je tiens à mes enfants
xavier est l'agressé adrien à tous les
jours qui vont de domaine à tous les
jours vous m'inspirez affaires plus et à
faire mieux et tout ce que je fais je le
fais pour vous et votre génération
vous me rappeler à tous les jours le
prendre des instants pour apprécier la
vie qu'on vit ensemble et la chance
qu'on a et de tous les rôles que
j'assume être votre papa c'est celui que
je préfère
je vous aime tellement j'ai entendu
votre message ce soir vous voulez
continuer d'avancer avec nous mais vous
voulez aussi vous assurer que la voix du
québec se porte encore plus à ottawa et
je vous donne ma parole
mon équipe et moi serons là pour vous
[Applaudissements]